пластикові пакети
запал сумний португалію ще 40 років
будинків вона була аграрною Україною і все
продукти тут був і органічним і
обпалених при пасив нині португалія і
чемпіоном євросоюзу
за викурю станемо пластикових пакетів
шкіряний житель баку ростові він відпив
1000 штук
нарік на таких гнівний рекорд відомі
таєць але на кошти вид побачи а
гумором застарілі комедійну фігуру
мілан коміка і вино шаблею, що охолонув тебе
португальців з чоловіком пекельному з встиг
ство
людина з двома пластиковими пакетами
пластикові пакети не б говорити люди
на хоче займається ми важливі або
центральним та харчуванням і червоні
пластикові пакети повилітають їжу
реальності он і я запалив з готовим
банальним та кемп важливі вам та миси бнф
потиснув з пласта кума поки це і 7
вигадаємо милом комік хоче і своїми
пластиковими пакетами продуманий суворо ти
абсурдно в жити і життєдай ну ну як
стопі година зйомок цього серіалу
я хочу показати ще такого
португальської в кульці
показують і португальці без пакету всі
ще показують її хамфрі богарта без
ігорка
ідея образу мілан куміко з підлогою та мети
на думку колвін у зловивши себе на тому що
сам 3 травня в руках два пакети
apple і розгорнувся такумі ти всі ми ж
завжди школа припиняють тепла стикові
роби пластику і доки ту португалії
скрізь і не місяця клей по валентину але
адже на поверховий газетою ви ходите
по каті
пластиковий пакет для ніг htc син був по
кожен даного смугу приватного споживача
рекамье і винсом сара густоти зустрічно
руди на з двома дітьми обтрусила щодня
забираючись і школи закупівлі прокатування та
gc1000 роботом це приземленого чайну
ти ну я типу хіт до супермаркету
саме супермаркет я не б ми викреслимо
рудова ніж пластикових пакетів теле орди
покриття всіх волин завищують стіни
цілу торговому центру самі
португальці без спрут його здалися їм
ми португальці вже дійсно фільму
показують і пальцем на in show
дурять нас у сида про особи стоїть паві
дальність за asus пиляє обр досвід ніхто і
від клімату екології неактивний
колективний перфідо я ще й далі
відкривати ми португальці рано через нос
ринула в море з пластику та ноги та
доходить до абсурду
запакований ще раз запаковується в
поспіль і шкіряний продукт України від ж
кульках дошку що в ній для ти хто б
дати 3 екологічно свідомі снують так
дзвони екологічніше коси тут покритої
платні 2 центи за штуку
вищих касах ланцюг запакували на v2 загальному
пакетів слідує новий безкоштовних пакетів
човники купівлі кіру це поклик земні
екологічними merkur одним і я прийшла
сюди будуть ніхто настоявши за купувати та
всього один пакет цілий яка під і
продавця-то пуруша звучний по риб'ячих
касі пакет буду на те ваш ким порветься
я спроба питання ти вище один пакет вин
іронічно посміхнувся не хоч і в
сказати гей ну товаришу ти справжній
чемпіона теж ябеда всі ринку вир позову
і сказавши собі окей небудь
фундаменталістам і ми собі ще один
поки тоді будинком коли португальці
мабуть вниз про може атрибути себе
провал екології
на червоні з одного за хоч ти написав на
дверях приватного талакана місяць і кому
про ціну на ринг них учнів впав чат і
чий кому 6 нав'язувати і панує
ще можна його
метафоричністю свого виду чоловіка з
плакати з 1000 знаків
задумайся про свою з пожувати скупку в
дінку